bienvenue à cette toute première
émission d'infoman et oui c'est ma
nouvelle maison ici tout une tour de
plaisir voilà vingt ans cette année quel
format nous offre son regard singulier
sur l'actualité à youtube ou un heureux
mélange de satire de sarcasmes et
d'humour est-ce que je suis à trois
rivières ou b je suis à new york
mais au-delà de ça alors bras sont jean
rené dufort et saab en deux tours ou
s'il voyait d'informer notamment nous
présentant des facettes disons moins
connus de l'actualité de ses acteurs
et là mes yeux d'enfant quand justin
baro garni je peux tu revenir au revoir
pitch on dirait ça comment à
l'exclusivité de brendan et déco et toi
aussi tu formes à donner au décrypteurs
on était curieux de savoir ce que jean
rené pons de la désinformation
[Musique]
est ce que tu fais partie de ceux qui
disent ben on n'y peut rien ou au
contraire y ait quelque chose à faire
encore combattre des informations non
moi je suis en intégrant de de combattre
la désinformation
parce que il ya tellement de pièges et
il faut résister à ça parce que il faut
se rappeler que malgré tout notre
tentative d'attirer l'attention y auriez
plus intéressant et d'impressionnants
que la vérité et pour ma première
entrevue je vous donne le choix soit on
parle d'avortement soit on parle de
slogans des partis politiques moi je
trouve qu'il ya la fecq news est un
ennemi mais la demie fait news est
encore un pays ennemi coiffer et nihous
tu peux pas de battre une demi-feuille
news tu peux te battre quand une fête
news peut prouver que c'est faux a peu à
voir la vie longue
mais demi fake news soucier ça c'est
l'ennemi je savoir m'assurer peut-être
un service à la clientèle après vente
si monsieur charest avait bien fait ça
que mon invitation une forme de
journalisme que tu fais que par l'humour
on peut arriver justement à transmettre
une certaine vérité à propos de ce qui
s'y passe oui mais moi je pense ça
toujours été un
je trouve un faux débat qu'est-ce qui
est un journaliste
qu'est-ce qui est pas un journaliste moi
je pense que c'est au public à
déterminer ses sources d'information
sont elles crédibles
j'irais même jusqu'à dire que le clown
devant toi va parler compte
l'information spectacle c'est fou
l'objet étant c'était moi le clown de
l'information spectacle des fois j'ai
l'impression qu'après 20 est en jeu
c'est moi qui est devenu le stress juste
ajuster bravo mais aussi son deuxième
combat que je veux gagner plus souvent
l'approché jean pascal bonne chance pour
les publicités négatives
merci c'est un peu ma job l'information
spectacle sadi de mètres du spectacle
dans l'information mais il faut pas tout
facile inverse
ils prennent du spectacle tu rajoutes
matip et d'informatique je fais des
conférences dans les écoles puis la pose
la question je dis bon mettons céline
galipeau à vous présente un reportage
quelque chose qui s'est passé en iran ou
en syrie
elle vous le dit super sérieusement le
gouvernement bernois n'accepte de
suspendre l'offensive militaire
controversé dans le nord de la syrie
vous reprenez la même fine mais sur le
reportage de la petite musique comique
gouvernement and one accepte de
suspendre l'offensive militaire
controversé dans le nord de la syrie
500 morts dont une centaine de civils
plus ou moins sérieux là j'essaie de
voir où il y accorde le sérieux ou le
sérieux n'a été entamée parce que moi je
fais souvent saoûls il ya toujours de la
musique sommet un reportage que ce ça
fait est que ça fait que je fais de
l'information spectacle ou parce que le
spectacle peu servi et justes a
contrasté à nouvelle mais il peut aussi
la détruit complètement parfois les
jeunes venus se démène pour rendre cette
matière un peu aride très intéressante
bien certain nombre de personnes qui
s'informent via les émissions comme la
tienne qui sont prédire satirique mais
ces derniers c'est pathétique aux états
unis alors toujours senti qu'il y avait
un certain respect de notre rigueur
infoman et ça je suis à ses
tortionnaires dans le bureau recherche
et orson
oui ben on va chercher de l'information
et non seulement on transmet cette
information là mais on va sûrement
rajouter quelque chose pour taquiner la
personne à la base de cette information
là vous êtes bébé en mauvaise il est
député fait que si l'information est
fausse c'est certain que en aimant la
mise en demeure arrive nous on rajoute
souvent l'insulté à l'injure quand on
envoie une information donc il faut
doublement vérifier et peut se tromper
est ce que cette année on a brisé notre
justin demeure la même personne ne me
mettre dans le trouble des fois quand je
les gros puis est arrivé 2016 un certain
donald trump et iam de viol - est-ce que
ça changer les choses je les mettrai
dans un courant plus général qui est
arrivé que les réseaux sociaux les
médias ne sont plus la courroie entre
les politiciens et le public il aime
beaucoup ça parce que il n'y a pas de
filtre c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent dire
à peu près n'importe quoi c'est pour ça
que je trouve que les chroniques les
émissions de des preuves des faits et
c'est si important
chaque mot d'un des politiciens
devraient être vérifiée on devrait avoir
le résultat est vrai c'est pas vrai
pourquoi parce que parce que parce que
lorsque nous assurons de sélectionner
des 100 g en fonction des besoins du
marché du travail
concept décrypteurs ces consciences la
cfu c'est complètement fou tout et
n'importe quoi qui se dit que ces cris
est inquiet oui je suis inquiet et c'est
souvent la faute des médias parce que
c'est vrai que les scientifiques
quand ils vont produire une étude plus
sexy il aura un petit peu plus sexy et
l'as bressols le journaliste voit passer
cette étude blogs tels aliments
pourraient prévenir certains types de
cancer c'est pas le fun puis on va plus
des laves encore guéri du cancer de la
prostate et là ça marche plus et en
sciences tu peux pas
faire ça c'est l'année coton ouaté 90 %
des gens sont d'accord avec moi sur mon
fils wally m'ont dit c'est pas un bon
argument
nous sommes tous dans des médias qui ont
faim qui sont affamés d'avoir un clic de
se faire regarder d'avoir une petite
publicité un peu plus cher on a faim on
est souvent le pire ennemi de nous-mêmes
je pense que des médias famille c'est
pas bon pour l'information
un exemple politique est flagrant de ça
c'est le fameux baiser qui est jamais
arrivé entre justin zongo et melania toi
oui les jamais rien arrivé
les journalistes ont pris sa vision
d'optique presque oui et on demand c'est
pas vrai on va dire regardez ce moment à
la fin c'était pauvre et et on a toute
la gamme télédiffusé une demie cette
news mais je me sens femme demi fait
nous a manqué le synadec
scandale un premier ministre embrasse
sur la bouche sont animateurs préférés
mais ce qu'on peut quand même de garder
un petit degré d'optimisme face à tout
ça mais je j'espère qu'on peut se garder
un peu d'optimisme et ça va prendre
quelque chose que l'humanité ou en
grandes carences de la rigueur et je
pense qu'on n'a pas présentement la
rigueur sur les réseaux sociaux et dans
les médias pour justement se dit
regardez ça c'est pas vrai on voit pas
en parler puis ça on augmente la
nouvelle faussement de leurs professeurs
mais c'est le fun autres cas de jaser
avec toi je remercie mon cher c'est fini
bas